احد عشر اسبوعا على تولينا ياهو رئاسه
وزراء اسرائيل وبحلول هذه المرحله تقريبا
كان معظم القاده الاسرائيليين الجدد منذ
سبعينيات القرن الماضي قد زاروا الولايات
المتحده او التقوا برئيسها لكن معنا
نتنياهو هذه المره الامر مختلف لا دعوه من
البيت الابيض بعد واشنطن رفضت التعليق على
الامر وهذا ما يدل على ان الولايات
المتحده حاليا تنظر الى حكومه نتنياهو على
انها مزعجه وغير مرحب بها على اجنده
الاداره بحسب صحيفتها الاسرائيليه
التقارير الصحفيه الامريكيه والاسرائيليه
تشير الى تحفظ امريكي على برنامج تغيير
القضاء الذي تقترحه حكومه نتنياهو لكن
اداره بايدن تفضل المحادثات الهادئه على
الانتقادات العالميه وفق مسؤولا كبير في
الخارجيات الامريكيه
وان حملت التصريحات العالميه انتقادات
عندما تتطلع الى اجراء تغييرات كبيره
الاصلاحات الرئيسيه في قوانينك في مؤسستك
ربما يكون الاجماع هو الاكثر اهميه بهذا
الخصوص والتاكد من ذلك ليس امرا مقبولا
فقط بل سيستمر وهي مساله دائمه
الغضب الامريكيه برز في زياره وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
بحسب موقعي ولا اشار الى ان مسؤلي
الخارجيه الامريكيه قالوا قبل الزياره في
محادثات انهم سيكونون سعداء اذا لم يقم
سموتريتش بزياره واشنطن الذي دعا الى محو
بلده حوار الفلسطينيه وان قام بالزياره لم
يلتقي به اي مسؤولا امريكيا رسمي لكن هل
يمكن ان يتوسع الامر لدول اكثر وان يصل
الامر لمقاطعه نتنياهو بنفسه رابطه حقوق
الانسان في فرنسا انتقدت زياره سموتريتش
المقرره غدا الى فرنسا واكدت انه غير مرحب
به في باريس اما قاده التظاهرات في
اسرائيل المحتجين على خطط تغيير القضاء
وعلى رفض نتنياهو مقترح الرئيس للوساطه
والحل توجهوا بنداء الى زعماء العالم ككل
قاطع نتنياهو ووزرائه